sources tell CBS News the talks to
prevent another government shutdown and
broken down ahead of a budget deadline
Congress has until midnight on Friday to
reach an agreement over immigration and
border security but a new demand by
Democrats has become an obstacle Nancy
Cordes is watching negotiations on
Capitol Hill Nancy good morning good
morning and the reason the time is of
the essence here is because lawmakers
really need to finalize a deal today if
they want to write up legislation and
get it passed in the House and Senate by
Friday but right now they are deadlocked
over Immigration and Customs Enforcement
or ice Democrats want to limit the
number of undocumented migrants that the
agency can detain by capping the number
of beds in ice detention centers they
argue that the administration's
enforcement roundups are out of control
Republicans say ice detains criminals
and that a cap would hinder that mission
now at the heart of this negotiation of
course is the 5.7 billion dollars in
border wall funding that is being sought
by the president right now we're told
negotiators are looking at a much lower
figure between 1.3 and 2 billion dollars
for a boarder barrier mostly new and
replacement fencing and we don't know if
the president would be willing to accept
that White House officials say mr. Trump
is determined to get that money one way
or the other
Noora deadline day today Nancy thank you
so much